hi there by now you've probably heard
about the government shutdown tons of
non-essential workers like me have been
furloughed monuments have been closed
the Panda cam has been turned off but
that's not the worst of it
government-run Twitter accounts have
been shut down it takes a lot of
resources to tweet we usually condense a
5,000 word essay down to 140 characters
also we need hashtag experts twitter is
an essential one-way communication tool
for the federal government to express
viewpoints without any distracting media
commentary government tweets bring you
extremely useful information every day
and now they need you to get back up and
running so help me help them so we can
continue to get tweets like these from
our favorite washingtonians Helen Keller
was born hashtag on this day 1880
drinking more water is an easy choice
that everyone can make beware lots of
funny pics of fireball being posted to
Facebook etc so you might be wondering
what do i get for my contribution pledge
fifteen dollars and we'll send you a
personalized thank you tweet with the
hashtag government is awesome pledge
fifty dollars and get an I heart my big
government t-shirt sorry one size fits
all pledge one hundred dollars and we'll
get our friends the IRS to give you a
one hundred dollar tax deduction so it's
like you never spend anything pledged
twenty thousand dollars and get a
bailout from the government because you
probably work in the financial industry
offer does not expire so donate now
because until we raise the necessary
funds your twitter account feeds are
going to be stuck with hashtags shut
down pick up lines forever back to
typing